this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond register for free at
dndbeyond.com to start your adventure
[Music]
from the company who can't make their
own spider-man movie or streaming
service or enough ps5s comes the one
thing sony can still deliver
a top-notch galleon rom-com
venom let there be carnage
if you're making a film about a
squirrely guy who talks to himself you
call gollum to direct it andy circus
helms 2021 sequel to 2018 surprise hit
of 1996 packed with bad cgi goo
bad wigs you said it and british actors
doing really bad american accents okay
this is about me wanting to live without
you whining in my ear all the time about
eating bad guys i just incapacitated
your boyfriend and only you at the life
foundation when that rocket exploded
wait is this what it sounds like to them
when i go or mary poppins which way to
the queen
catch up with eddie brock and his
parasite venom to
roommates who spend every minute coming
in and out of each other eddie's
journalism career has stalled because
he's an idiot it's a house never mind
and venom just can't help killing people
another one bites the dust
they had families enjoy their wacky
dynamic where venom reacts in real time
to eddie's crappy life you suck you're
shocked excuse me and ignore how awkward
it must be for the people who can't hear
his voice congratulations thank you
what
as this film leans hard into the simrock
shippers fantasies to make a gayer
superhero movie than the one with actual
gay superheroes in it hello gorgeous
sorry no god not my type you just said
that you loved me
um i am out
of the eddy closet
watch as venom is pushed to the brink by
the only guy named cletus to get an
interracial marriage he began life as a
twilight reject lip-synching to woody
harrelson they can't take you from me
you're my one bright light then became a
monster infected by the guy fieri virus
which um
[Music]
hands
he's an unnaturally born killer on a
rampage to elope with shriek whose
marvel's answer to dc's black canary
except she um see the the difference is
that uh
okay i guess he's just dc's black canary
and nothing can stop these two lovebirds
from being together except fire
or sound
or the fact that her superpower is
making loud noises
see this is why truffles are so hard to
balance that's why michelle williams got
sidelined in this wood i just needed a
little space after the whole
alien biting a guy's head off thing
dive into an ever-expanding universe of
the ip still controlled by sony pictures
until morbius eats dirt at the box
office and they start from scratch again
featuring some of marvel's most iconic
buildings newspaper names and metaphors
until he just give up at the end and
blip venom into the mcu or whatever in a
move that thrilled mainstream comic book
nerds while the real eagle-eyed dorks
are trying to figure out why venom
crosses over with beverly hills cop too
wait are we finally getting a cinematic
eddie verse oh man the possibilities are
endless
so enjoy the first comic book film in a
long while that understood the
assignment that doesn't try to imitate
some other genre or stuff itself with
oscar-worthy pretensions just 90 minutes
of dumb fun about a reporter in love
with his tapeworm still would have been
even better if they had encouraged to
end at just one scene earlier
this guy
see that cinema
starring
rock bottom
vinnie's with benny's i support my large
adult son
michelle williams after venom one oh god
i'm never doing that again god will
maybe never i don't know honestly it's
really fun cletus the snap jaw yokel
hall attack girl
and another british tomboy
man venom's got a type doesn't he venom
let him carnage
how does venom keep sprouting tentacles
out of betty's back without ripping
holes in his clothes wait is venom just
pretending to be tom hardy's clothes and
he's actually naked the entire time oh
man
this just got even hotter
this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by d d beyond's battle for beyond
subscribe to ddb's youtube to join the
battle
merhaba we need to name the baby
chewbacca
i'm gonna put some dirt in your eye
you know i have a hormone disorder